no new year's eve fireworks in the year
of covid
instead this is the skyline of london
bathed in a familiar
electric glow as it is on any other
winter night
this is a city like much of the country
hunkered down
and mostly inside shielded from the
catastrophe
that was 2020.
the celebrations haven't stopped
completely even though people can't hit
the pubs and clubs
there is a groove to be found on the web
and this was the vibe from the hacienda
nightclub
a 24-hour live stream bouncing tunes
across the internet
taking the party online virtual raving
may not be the same
but at least all ages can take part
olly meers from manchester was certainly
smashing it
with his kids adaptation
and innovation has been the order of the
day to deal with the ever-changing rules
chef tom shepherd turned his restaurant
into a supper club
he boxes up ingredients for you to cook
up your own fine dining experience
happy new year and welcome to the dining
home cooking on
last one of 2020 and shows you how
in youtube videos the original thought
and concept of it was a case of just
getting us back in work and
making ends meet and now we fast forward
to new year's eve where we've
done an absolute bumper sell out of the
whole of november and december
and uh you know it's become its own
business entirely and we've brought
pleasure to people's homes
in this year which i think is that for
me is the main
is the main objective it's also been
incredibly frustrating even for the most
entrepreneurial
oliver tully was hoping to be screening
movies at his drive in cinema
over the festive season but had to close
when his area moved into tier four i
feel sorry for customers
but i also feel really sorry for
businesses like us you know who are just
the events industry
is one of the hardest hit industries
along with the travel industry
through all of this pandemic the
beginning of 2020 now seems like a world
away
when the fireworks exploded above the
capital there were few signs that a
pandemic was on its way
which would consume our way of life
it has been a brutal year and from
westminster you can see it in microcosm
the infighting of brexit ending in the
finale in the house of commons but that
turned out to be a sideshow
in the face of the pandemic over here
saint thomas hospital
still inundated with coronavirus
patients
and it's where the prime minister had
his own close call with the virus
and on this side the london eye no
fireworks no spectacular
show it could be a symbol for cancelled
plans
and celebrations
but there is hope the vaccine rollout is
gathering steam
and in newcastle the faintest glint of
optimism
here fireworks were let off from secret
locations
so people wouldn't be tempted to gather
outside
it marks a new beginning and the end of
what has been
a terrible year alex rossi sky news